on est toujours là onevent de vacances
un peu plus tôt que prévu c'est pas
encore la saison 3 c'est notre
intersaison à nous euh parce que on
s'est dit qu'on avait peut-être encore
des choses intéressantes à raconter
peut-être pas nous mais nos invités oui
alors on vous proposer une série de
trois podcasts un peu hors série qu'on
va appeler l'intersaison d'envergure le
premier c'est donc maintenant romain et
Manu sont avec moi messieurs bonjour
bonjour bonjour et notre invité il
s'appelle Frank cun et vous entendez il
est pas loin d'un gymnase il est dans un
gymnase je sais pas ouais dans le Gy
dans le gymnase à Beaublanc ouais
bonjour à tous bonjour médaillé de
bronze il y a peu quand même le
préparateur physique de l'équipe de
France de
basket également au CSP limoge
évidemment on a plein de questions donc
on attaque tout de suite l'intersaison
d'envergure la partie 1 un podcast
poster dunk et on y va tout
droit
alors
Franck je vais laisser romain faire ta
présentation premièrement parce que moi
moi j'ai j'ai vu j'ai vu ton CV mais
j'en sais pas plus il te connais mieux
que moi et c'est quand même plus facile
que de te demand à toi ah je vais ouais
on va même à limite te demander toi à
Franck peut-être de faire un rapide
rapide point sur ton parcours si ce n
que moi je peux je peux juste ajouter
que bon c'est Franck c'est un coach de
basket que que j le l'occasion de
croiser assez assez
régulièrement ces dernières années
notamment l'an dernier où j'is souvent
limoge et qui une facilité d'échange qui
qui est quand même très très
intéressante pour quelqu'un qui a côtoyé
le haut niveau et qui fait également
partie des des RAR personne à à s'être
exporté avoir travaillé à l'étranger
donc il y a vraiment une transversalité
dans le propos qui ne peut que que faire
du bien à tout le monde donc après bah
Fran si tu veux faire un petit rappel
rapide sur ton parcours ça peut être ça
peut être parfait écoute c'est c'est
sympa la présentation c'est vrai que que
qu'aujourd'hui j'essaie d'avoir une une
certaine curiosité sur ce qui se fait au
plus haut niveau dans dans dans les
staffs de basket mais aussi sur sur
d'autres sports parce que je pense qu'il
y a des des choses à prendre un peu
partout et et mon parcours m'amène à
avoir une vision assez globale de de ce
qui aujourd'hui le staff du haut niveau
et et c'est ce que j'essaie d'amener
petit à petit àmoch al si je devais
résumer un petit peu ce que bon j'ai
toujours j'ai toujours entraîné parce
que mon père est a été entraîneur donc
sur sur les gymnases de l'âge de 12 13
ans je faisais les passes quand mon père
entraînait les cadets de France du du FC
Mulous basket tu vois à l'époque c'était
le MBC donc c'est moi qui faisait les
les rebonds les passes et et ensuite
j'ai commencé à à entraîner sur des des
des catégories minimes j'étais sur le
pôle avec tarassed et j'avais les minim
France deélectricité Strasbourg tu sais
où sont passés yanniit bocolo h Jason
bar donc la SIG ne faisait pas encore
tellement de formation à cette époque
puis un passage à la SIG avec olidier
Wester donc c'est là que j'ai commencé à
entraîner sur les CAD des France euh le
centre de formation du de la C où j'ai
pu avoir la chance d'avoir les espoirs
aussi j'avais comm comme responsable
technique du club Frédéric s donc est
quand même un formateur qui qui a sa
réputation donc j'ai j'ai pu apprendre
pas mal de choses sur sur les aspects
Technic tactiques à cette époque et et
beaucoup de travail en collaboration
avec avec
Olivier tu sais j'ai j'ai toutes ces
périodes aussi où j'ai ciller un peu le
haut niveau donc ma première année au
club c'était avec an veis et Bob Sud là
ensuite j'ai eu les années avec Erric
donc j'ai pu avoir la chance d'être
présent à Bery le soir du du du seul
titre pour le moment de de la SIG hein
titre de champion de France et euh et
l'année où où Vincent colollet est
arrivé à la SIG je me suis exporté en
Roumanie voilà euh sur ma spécificité
qui était à l'époque la préparation
physique parce que pour moi la prépa
physique c'est 25 % à peu près de la
performance donc tu as la
techniqueaspect tactique l'aspect mental
et l'aspect physique et pour moi c'était
un aspect qui était qui était totalement
délaissé donc j'ai essayé de d'apporter
quelque chose un peu là-dessus et et
rapidement ça fait ma réputation mais
mais aujourd'hui je revendique vraiment
de de ne pas être qu'un préparateur
physique parce que ça fait ça fait
vraiment depuis les années 98 2000 que
je coach HM j'ai tout voilà donc euh sur
l'équipe de France j'ai un rôle très
ciblé sur la préparation physique mais
tu sais que c'est un staff très
plétorique donc on a tous une mission
très restreinte et c'est voilà c'est
c'est l'avantage des St plétorique c'est
ce que j'allais dire c'est que là on est
vraiment par expertise après au niveau
c'est c'est c'est ça aussi exactement et
c'est et c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est
important euh je veux te juste te faire
un petit point sur mes expérience à
l'étranger donc j'ai je suis parti sur
de la prépa physique et et j'ai la la
particularité d'être parti sur des
équipes de handball donc j'ai fait j'ai
fait du hand féminin j'ai fait du hand
masculin j'ai eu des très beaues équipes
on a été en finale de la Champions
League avec un club
roumain champion de Roumanie deux fois
champion de Russie avec un club de
rostof où il y a eu Siraba Dembélé
captaine de l'équipe de France de
handball qui était là-bas Barbosa enfin
des gros joueurs pour ceux qui
connaissent un petit peu le handbal et
un coach français Fred Boujan avec qui
j'ai pu j'ai pu travailler moi ce que je
retiens de de cette expérience
c'est la capacité de management de staff
et la capacité de management des hommes
qu'on les qu'on les entraîneurs
internationaux de handb donc ça c'est
c'est quelque chose
qui qui m'a vraiment tu vois qui m'a
vraiment changé de de du coach français
très axé technico- tactique et j'ai pu
découvrir une façon de manager qui était
ben quand même beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus abouti que que celle que nous on a
h et donc retour à à limoge ou enfin
retour pas du tout arrivé à limoge et
là-bas donc tu es préparateur physique
mais aussi formateur
ouais mais si tu veux je suis arrivé à
limoge à la demande de d'Olivier
bourguin pour être assistant coach mais
assistant coach avec la casquette si tu
veux la mission de préparation physique
et la mission aussi de trava de travail
individuel mais pas que physique basket
aussi sur les joueurs et d'assistant
vidéo donc ma première aré limoge ben
c'est c'est moi qui suis sur l'urocup en
en en vidéo je travaille avec les
joueurs individuellement donc mon mon
mon champ de de toute façon c'était ma
volonté c'était j'avais d'autres
solutions d'autres propositions et je
voulais revenir au basket donc là au
basket et pas de manière restreinte sur
le sur la partie prépa physique bon la
partie prépa physique je su vraiment
toujours la la piloter mais d'avoir
aussi des missions basket et ça Olivier
me l'a me l'a offert avec ce nouveau
staff qui était composé de de King
François ponis très bien ensuite ensuite
ça a évolué parce que Medy Marie a fait
a eu le souhait de partir pour aller sur
des staff pro donc il est parti en
Suisse à nechâel et il y a eu un besoin
sur le sur le centre de formation moi ce
que j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai proposé au club
c'est de dire voilà tout le travail
d'individualisation qu'on a mis en place
notamment avec
souya avec les pros quoi parce que tout
ce qui a été mis en place sur les pros
c'est un suivi vraiment très très
individualisé sur le plan technique sur
le plan tactique sur le plan physique
euh de de de l'élargir au centre voilà
de dire pourquoi est-ce que aujourd'hui
l'imoge ne pourrait pas avoir un centre
de formation ambitieux avec des joueurs
prospects et des des un staff euh un
staff élargi qui qui peut proposer de la
préparation physique du travail
technique et cetera h et on est parti
là-dessus aujourd'hui c'est la alors tu
sais que les hommes ont changé à l'image
he il y nouveau une nouvelle présidence
mais aujourd'hui la direction a souhaité
a souhaité continuer ce projet là donc
donc on m'a donné les moyens de de
continuer à aller dans cette direction
la formation étant aujourd'hui
importante pour le CSP donc moi je suis
très très heureux de de pouvoir
participer à ce projet qui ont développé
ok ben on va commencer là-dessus
finalement on avait prévu de le faire
dans l'autre sens mais c'est très bien
on va commencer par le centre de
formation on finira par l'équipe de
France OK euh tu le donc on l'a bien
compris tu tu le bâtis un peu de de de
rien c'est ce centre de formation c'est
un projet c'est un projet tout nouveau
et est-ce que tu peux concrètement
expliquer à quelqu'un qui connaîtrait
pas du tout comment ça fonctionne quand
un joueur arrive dans le centre de
formation qu'est-ce qui se passe comment
on va le faire progresser avec quels
outils avec quel coach et cetera bien
sûr alors si tu veux la faulté majeure
pour les centres de formation
aujourd'hui en France c'est que il y a
c'est pas comme au foot où tout est tout
est aménagé c'est-à-dire que tu as tes
profs qui viennent les joueurs sont sont
là tout est aménagé donc ils peuvent
avoir un cours ensuite ils vont sur le
terrain bon en en basket les les moyens
étant réduit c'est beaucoup plus déjà
c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué là on a réussi au niveau du
CSP avoir des aménagements scolaires
donc ça fait qu'un jeune qui vient chez
nous il va pouvoir être sur le terrain
le matin donc on a des créneaux 8h15
9h30 sur lesquels il va avoir du
perfectionnement technique ou physique
mais de manière totalement individualisé
c'est-à-dire un coach euh un joueur un
coach deux joueurs maximum alors ça
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment à la base de de ma réflexion
c'est arrêtons de proposer des des des
contenus collectifs euh par exemple de
préparation physique ou ou de travail
par poste tu vois c'est-à-dire avoir
tous tes joueurs tous tes joueurs euh
extérieur ou tout tes jours intérieur
sur la même thématique alors que les
besoins euh sont très sont très
différents d'un individu à l'autre HM
voilà donc d'abord on fait un diagnostic
en fait oui ouais mais pour pouvoir
faire ça il te faut il te faut un staff
parce que même si je suis le meilleur
formateur de France et que je travaille
avec 20 gamins euh je ne pourrais
finalement que travailler si je veux
individualiser les choses que je suis
sur le terrain je vais être limité dans
ma capacité à pouvoir pouvoir faire ber
je
OK et donc vas-y continue donc là je
vais un petit peu plus loin donc ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a essay là on a essayé
de convaincre le club c'est staffer
staffer c'était staffer et staffer avec
de la compétence donc ça c'est ce qu'on
a aujourd'hui réussi à mettre en place
aujourd'hui le centre de formation c'est
5 coach donc aucun centre de formation
en France ne peut ne pe proposer C coach
tous ces coach sont un temps plein
c'està-dire que on est là à 8h on part à
20h
on travaille toute la journée et on
travaille en staff en collaboration dans
dans ce staff de de C coach on a un
préparateur physique à temps plein qui
était mon stagiaire l'année passée qu'on
a salarié fa cour donc qui est diplômé
qui est compétente une trentaine
d'années on a la compétence de
yassinawadi qui avait un comment dire
une intervention limitée sur les
professionnels l'année passée donc on
pas besoin de le présenter mais mais il
a travaillé avec S coup d'bouya avec ou
l' dans je vous l'avez déjà eu je crois
euh en podcast donc lui il a il a
souhaité avoir des missions plus
élargies sur sur les jeunes potentiels
du centre ce qui est aujourd'hui chose
faite ça veut dire que le matin sur les
sur les perfectionnements c'est Yassine
qui est présent ce qui est fantastique
pour pour nos jeunes du centre euh
Yassine pilote le perfectionnement
technique individualisé ensuite on a
Julien ma qui est l'entraîneur de U18
pareil jeune entraîneur très motivé très
compétent qui a à temps plein et on a la
chance d'avoir en plus un assistant
centre de formation qui est Clémentin
Alix qui était au m la saison passée qui
lui
aussi jeune jeune coach qui a des des
des d'excellentes compétences sur sur la
vidéo qui qui a une soif d'apprendre qui
est un état d'esprit mais fantastique
qui ajoute encore pour nous de la
compétence et de l'encadrement de de ces
jeunes donc on est on est véritablement
5 coach et combien de joueurs donc sur
les joueurs sur les matinées on est sur
un volume à peu près de 12 13 joueurs h
et sur ces 12 13 joueurs on a on a
suivant les priorités donc on définit
des priorités par jeunes le spectre il
peut aller de d'une priorité très forte
sur le physique parce que c'est c'est un
passage obligé ou une priorité très
forte sur le technique parce que c'est
vraiment un manque pour le joueur une
fois qu'on a défini le spectre sur un un
certain nombre de perfectionnement je
sais pas on va prendre un chic par
exemple sur quatre perfectionnements il
va avoir trois perfectionnements
orientés technique voir quatre ça peut
être 100 % ou alors il va avoir 50 % il
va avoir 50 % de perf physique 50% 50 %
de perf technique ensuite on va y rester
le temps nécessaire pour avoir un gain
et le gain il doit être significatif
parce que travailler et ensuite il faire
allez 35 minutes de tel de tel thème par
semaine ça ça permet pas le progrès donc
on va rester sur un thème et on va
insister ça peut être l'agressivité ça
peut être la finition ça peut être le
tir ça peut être différents aspects le
le bending et on va y rester jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait un réel progrès pour le joueur
donc si c'est un mois si c'est 3 mois si
c'est 4 mois l'importance pour nous
c'est que sur cet aspect là au bout de 6
mois on puisse dire voilà on a corrigé
et il y a il y a quoi vous avez un
catalogue d'exercices vous discutez des
exer 6 entre vous vous avez un programme
comment ça marche alors sur les si tu
veux d'abord on a on a des réunions sur
lesquelles on parle des jeunes donc on
définit nos nos priorités après on est
fortement piloté par Yassine qui nous
donne sa vision déjà du du du joueur à
savoir il détermine un profil donc il a
une fiche on discute de la fiche après
on est d'accord on n pas d'accord on
amène notre notre point de vue ensuite
on construit les séances donc sur la
construction de Séan il y a pas une
catalogue mais il y a une il y a un
objectif alors si tu es par exemple dans
le dans le travail de finition on va
essayer de le mettre en situation par
rapport à à à ce qu'on peut retrouver
dans le jeu plus important encore on va
utiliser la vidéo et sur la l'aspect de
vidéo on va essayer d'avoir des des
profil de joueur qui lui ressemble qui
sont dans le haut niveau donc tu peux
avoir je sais pas pour pour un poste 4
on va avoir ir des images de poste 4 qui
jouent l'eurolague de poste 4 qui jouent
NBA qui ont un profil qui ressemble à
notre joueur potentiel on va l'amener à
lui montrer des des des situations sur
lesquelles ce joueur est dominant on va
regarder on va discuter un petit peu de
la technique ensemble et ensuite on va
remettre le jeunne en situation sur le
terrain pour essayer de Ben de de de lui
faire apprendre ensuite de perfectionner
son geste c'estd qu'il y a pas de frite
en mousse chez vous sur sur les
entraînement individuels contrairement à
ce qu'on peut avoir parfois on est
vraiment c'est c'est quelque chose que
bon je rigole avec ça parce qu'on a
parlait souvent avec Yassine mais on est
dans l'idée de la contextualisation en
fait qui c'est ce que tu dis c'est très
très important c'est de remettre les
choses en perspective par rapport à ce
qui se fait à l'instanté pour le jeune
joueur sur le terrain et avec l'objectif
de Zir moi ce que j'appelle
l'entraînement invisible c'est le fait
d'aller chercher des infos comme de la
vidéo c'està-dire se mettre en
perspective en se disant voilà la
référence c'est ce que tu viens de dire
la référence à au niveau pour toi c'est
ce joueurlà ce joueurl ce joueurl voilà
ce sur quoi faut tendre et c'est c'est
c'est pour moi beaucoup plus plus
intéressant que de mettre 18 plot des
chaises des machins des conneries c'est
c'est voilà c'est recontextualisé c'est
la base de tout entraînement et c'est
pour ça que les pays les ex pays de
l'Est notamment sont très forts parce
qu'ils ne travaillent que comme ça sur
sur ces aspects de développement
individuel c'était ma question à quel
point déjà est-ce que c'est le le seul
club en France où on fait ça
vraiment avec 5 coach pour 12 joueurs
donc vraiment très très spécifique tu
travailles très SP écoute tout tout ce
que j'ai envie de te répondre c'est que
moi j'ai toujours eu ce r de travailler
comme ça et j'ai toujours été limité par
les moyens c'està-dire que à l'époque où
j'étais au centre de formation de
Strasbourg d'ailleurs c'est un centre
qui a énormément évolué est plus
ressemble plus du tout aujourd'hui à ce
qu'il était com moi j'y étais à l'époque
et d'ailleurs ils ont très très bien
très très bien évolué c'est super mais à
l'époque on était aussi limité par par
notre staff par notre structure et donc
tu as beau avoir l'idée si tu as pas les
les compétences si tu as pas les hommes
pour pouvoir l'organiser tuas pas
l'aménagement scolaire si tu as pas les
cinq coachs si tu as pas le terrain tu
peux pas le faire donc la question que
je pose tu me dis est-ce que les autres
centres travaillent comme ça moi je sais
une chose c'est que on est le seul
centre avec C coachs voilà voilà c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est super
important moi c'est c'est le constat que
j'ai fait je me suis promenis un petit
peu l'an dernier l'année d'avant dans
diff voir différents entraînement basket
mais pas seulement quand j'ai quand j'ai
visité les les installations du du stade
Rochel du stade Rochel rugby euh j'ai vu
j'ai vu comment dire comment ça
fonctionne en interne et très
sincèrement quand on parle de structure
aujourd'hui et là je fais le lien ce que
disait Franck on a souvent l'image de
club avec un open space avec 70 salariés
dans les bureaux des conneries et cetera
et cetera enfin des conneries non çaen
est pas mais dans les fait faut pas oubl
ce qui fait tourner un club oui c'est le
facteur économique mais si vous avez le
meilleur budget du monde avec deux
coachs et pour s'occuper de 40 joueurs
ça ne marche pas et quelque part pour
moi les structures c'est aussi être
capable de de de faciliter l'accueil
d'encadrer les gens correctement et de
permettre leur développement et leur
accompagnement c'estàd qu'un centre de
formation aujourd'hui il y a que deux
entraîneurs ce qui est le modèle lambda
en France parce que très souvent on a le
coach espoir qui assisté du coach cadet
parfois il y a quelqu'un qui traîne au
milieu ça fait TR mais la majorité des
clubs c'est ça aujourd'hui la la la la
situation de l'imuge elle est elle est
extrêmement intéressante parce que il y
a une volonté de structuration qui a été
faite sur le fait de staffer et le fait
de staffer c'est c'est d'avoir
suffisamment d'entraîneurs pour bosser
pour pas se perdre de toute façon une
équipe qu' soit une équipe pro une
équipe de centre de formation si vous
avez si vous avez 10 coachs sur du
travail pour 10 coachs j'exagère mais
c'est c'est quasiment ça donc là c'est
c'est pour moi c'est un ouais c'est un
vrai exemple de structuration à quel
point on est en retard par rapport à aux
pays qui sont en pointe en Europe on
parle pas des des États-Unis mais en
Europe ben écoute moi maintenant avec la
structure qu'on a mise en place
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est efficace
donc à mon avis euh euh on on on a déjà
montré avec les joueurs pro qu'on avait
par le passé on reviendra toujours à
l'exemple de ses coup mais il y a pas
que s coup william
Howard le passage de de tous les garçons
qui ont eu envie de travailler qui se
sont donnés des objectifs il y a eu une
progression donc aujourd'hui pour moi
tel qu'on est organisé on a pas besoin
de beaucoup plus on est efficace après
évidemment tu peux toujours aller plus
loin mais mais on a déjà ça c'est pareil
je voulais le souligner euh je t'ai
parlé des des coach mais je t'ai pas
parlé des dirigeants et on a nous des
dirigeants de Limoge qui aujourd'hui
encadre le centre de formation donc
Claude bolotni et Patrice Masso qui sont
des anciens qui ont les bonnes
connexions avec les lycées qui ont
permis les aménagements scolaires
notamment et permis de de faire de faire
les rouage ext sportif pour que nous sur
le terrain on puisse le mieux
fonctionner moi aujourd'hui je pense que
notre centre il a rien envé n'importe
quel autre centre on n pas besoin
beaucoup plus si ce n'est peut-être de
rajouter un deuxième terrain de rajouter
des panneaux bon on peut toujours aller
un petit peu plus loin mais dès
aujourd'hui on est on est efficace oui
mais je voulais dire combien depuis
combien d'années c'était en place à
l'étranger ah je sais je tu sais j'ai
pas assez de peut-être que Romain il
pourra mieux répondre à cette question
moi je connais bien le centre de
formation français euh à l'étranger j'ai
j'ai j'ai vu des choses fonctionner mais
je connais pas non plus tous les tous
les centres pe pas tellement je peux pas
tellement répondre à ta question à
l'étranger si tu veux la principale
différence qu'on va avoir
c'est que même si même même si euh les
les gens seront pas forcément plus
taffés que nous euh ils n'auront pas la
même contrainte que la nôtre avec les
rythmes scolaires c'est-à-dire que nous
c'est un paramètre qui est avec lequel
que moi j'ai été responsable de centre
de formation chez les filles et sur et
sur un club de probé le truc auquel on
Ste tout le temps y compris quand on a
des partenariats avec les lycées c'est
la dimension scolaire parce que tu vas
en Espagne tu vas en Italie euh tu vas
en Lituanie aussi où j'ai j'ai vu les
choses se faire c'est la contrainte
scolaire est différente c'est-à-dire que
le rythme quotidien n'est pas le même
nous aujourd'hui même avec des horaires
aménager si tu es pas au Centre Fédéral
euh bah tes entraînements ils sont comme
c'est le caranti par exemple ici où
c'est très tôt le matin ou alors c'est
c'est fin de journée tu t'entraînes
autour de 15 16 he parfois dans le
meilleur des cas alors que bah en
Espagne en Italie les rythmes sont
différents donc les gens peuvent
s'entraîner plutôt et je te dirais que
pour moi c'est un facteur qui euh je pas
dire limitant parce queon la dimension
éducation elle est essentielle et pour
pour plein de raisons euh pour plein de
raisons diverses et variées mais c'est
c'est quelque part aujourd'hui peut-être
le point de différence le plus important
par rapport à ce qui peut se faire en
c'est le vrai point de c'est le vrai
point de progrès parce que mais après ça
passera certainement comme pour le foot
par le privé c'est-à-dire que si on
arrive à à à fonctionner de manière
privée et avoir notre propre structure
euh avec un aménagement total on va
pouvoir aller plus loin encore HM pour
ça faut que T dirigeant il voi un
intérêt et le l'intérêt que tu vois je
pense quand tu as dir de toute façon
départ c'est l'intérêt économique
c'est-à-dire que si tu es capable toi
club aujourd'hui d'accompagner des
gamins et de ce que je vais dire c'est
c'est c'est grossir le trait mais de
mettre un gamin à la draft tous les tous
les 3 4 ans ou tous les 5 ans avec le
buyout que tu vas générer ainsi de suite
tu peux montrer que tu es viable
économiquement est-ce que c'est
suffisant aujourd'hui pour qu'un club
français se dise de manière intelligente
je vais réorienter une partie de mes
moyens vers ma structure de formation
pour permettre d'accéder à ça c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est toujours une
question une question qui importante je
prenais tout à l'HE l'exemple du ST
Rochely c'est c'est un club qui moi je
je suis pas du tout un grand amateur de
rugby he j'ai juste suivi ce qu'on m'a
expliqué quand j'y suis passé c'est un
club qui qui qui traînait toujours entre
le haut de la ProD2 et le bas du Top 14
et qui faisait la navette parce que
structurellement économiquement c'est un
petit peu difficile et un jour les pour
faire simple les dirigeants sur une
descente ont dit bah on va on va changer
de modèle de fonctionnement et ils sont
partis sur les modèles comme ça se fait
dans le foot anglais et ainsi de suite
ils ont ils ont fait construire avec des
partenaires un centre d'entraînement qui
est quelque chose aujourd'hui de très
très haut de gamme qui permet d'avoir
une unité de lieu où sont les pros le
centre de formation la filière féminine
ainsi de suite restauration collective
ce qui fait qu'en fait ça permet de tout
monitorer sur un seul endroit pardon
pour l' dééologiste anglophone là de
tout gérer tout surveiller sur un seul
endroit où finalement l'unité de lieu et
le fait d'être dans ces murs fait qu'il
a une autonomie sur énormément d'aspect
et c'est ce qui a permis aujourd'hui par
rapport à la prépa physique au fait
d'avoir des grands vestiaires une salle
de muscu des moyens et cetera et ca que
ce club qui est pas forcément le plus
riche soit devenu un club très important
parce que structurellement parlant il y
a pas d'équivalent a je pense que tu as
tu as 100 % raison je pense que le B
n'est pas le seul la seule option pour
pouvoir ramener des des revenu à mon
avis un centre de formation peut aussi
avoir ses propres sponsors parce que ça
V quand même une image d'éducation une
image de valeur une image positive de
progression donc il y a de plus en plus
à mon avis de étant donné qu'on on a les
moyens de de communiquer sur les centres
de formation aujourd'hui via les réseaux
sociaux via les les sites internet on va
pouvoir aussi avoir je pense des
partenaires qui vont faire des accords
avec nous pour pouvoir nous soutenir ça
me semble tout à fait envisageable à
l'avenir ce qui était pas le cas il y a
10 ans parce que le centre de formation
en fait n avait pas de visibilité alors
en parlant de de B cette année vous avez
Maxime Caren alors c'est cel c'est sueli
de le joueur de votre centre de
formation dont on a le plus parlé nous
puisque il a été dans les équipes de
France Jeune qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
va travailler est-ce que tu as le droit
de nous dire ce qui ce qui a été visé
pour lui qu'est-ce qu'il est en train de
travailler en ce moment Maxime Karine
non bien sûr maintenant j'ai simplement
pour un Maxime on est on prend un peu de
retard parce que Maxime est aujourd'hui
pas sur le terrain il est il est il est
blessé donc il a de blessé du du
championnat d'Europe et on a une on a
une problématique c'est que aujourd'hui
son son son son son niveau
d'entraînabilité est très faible donc il
est il est encore sur le sur le sur le
secteur médical et on attend d'avoir un
d'avoir un feu vert je pense si tu veux
qu'on peut on pourrait en rediscuter
dans quelques mois une fois que cette
cette question sera réglé que on aura
réellement un opérationnel qu'on aura
commencé à bosser ensemble j'ignorais
qu'il était encore blessé autant pour
moi ouais malheureusement mais
malheureusement c'est c'est quelque
chose qui a qui qui a été difficile pour
lui parce que h il a des problèmes de de
T trotulienne à la fin de sa saison au
niveau de du Centre fédéral et bon le
staff médical a estimé qu'il pouvait
participer au championnat d'Europe et
bon c'est des choses qui arrivent au
championnat d'Europe il a pas pu pas pu
être aussi bon que ce qu'il pensait il
avait il a été limité par ces blessures
et il est arrivé chez nous avec avec ça
donc aujourd'hui on est en gestion en
gestion de de de ces problèmes et du
coup en terme de d'entraînement est-ce
que est-ce que vous mélangez un peu les
postes tu parlais de de B and Ling par
exemple est-ce que des les grands
peuvent s'entraîner avec des meneurs et
cetera est-ce que vous arrivez à à faire
travailler tout le monde ensemble ou
c'est vraiment du du spécifique par
rapport au poste oui alors si tu veux on
a plusieurs types de de training
c'est-à-dire que en soirée on ne fait
pas du collectif comme une équipe de
National 2 qui va s'entraîner tous les
soirs pour préparer son match et et
gagner son match donc on a peu de
travail sur la ire ça peut arriver en
terme aussi de formation c'est parfois
intéressant quand même de savoir
préparer un match par rapport à ton ton
adversaire donc aviser pédagogique on
peut le faire mais on le fait pas de
manière systématisée on va travailler
collectivement le mercredi et le
vendredi et le mercredi on va être
plutôt sur du jeu rapide des situations
de pré collectif après le Lundi
Mardi Jeudi ça va être des soirées qui
vont être là aussi orienté sur le
travail individualiser mais sur ce so
ces soirées là on va comme tu l'as dit
essayer de mixer un peu c'està dire on
va plusant plutôt tendre vers du travail
par poste que vra un travail
individualisé pur de manière à ce qu'on
puisse euh faire des choses donc on peut
faire bosser le pivot le Big Man avec le
monur ensemble sur des thématiques de de
pick and roll de travail de passe sur
les pics de travail de chantroll on peut
amener des choses qui sont euh qui sont
de des des combinaisons donc c'est pas
tout à fait du pré collectif mais c'est
du travail technique encore une fois
contextualisé mais pas ciblé que sur un
joueur voà ça ça c'est le soir ça ça on
fera pas le matin le matin c'est
l'individu mais le soir on essaie
d'amener tu vois sur les postes de jeu
c'est c'est là où c'est intéressant
parce qu'en fait c'est pas sur la
formation on se perd un peu trop souvent
à avir des choses qui sont lié au 55 et
ainsi de suite mais finalement si tu
travailles tu es précos si tu travailles
ton avec des objectifs simples sur des
fondamentaux individuels et cetera et
cetera tu en as pas besoin tant que ça
du 55 pour faire évoluer tes joueurs le
55 il est important que si tu veux
gagner tes matchs à semaine mais est-ce
que c'est la priorité d'un centre de
formation alors oui quelque part les
résultats bah c'est c'est une vitrine et
ça t'amène des choses et il est toujours
préférable de pouir participer au du
futur au Trophée du futur et ainsi de
suite mais mais mais parce que c'est
comme ça quelque part que les dirigeants
puis public vont quantifier le travail
alors que c'est pas tout à fait vrai et
moi je reste persuadé que c'est
justement en contextualisant en
développant les choses que tu de cette
façonl que tu tu vas permettre à tes
gens de devenir efficace dans le 55
faire rciter les systèes de jeu tout le
mond peut le faire mais dans quel but et
et pour quel accompagnement du gamin
quoi on moi je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec toi c'est c'est un petit peu
l'esprit c'est de dire on nessaie pas on
essaie pas de les préparer à gagner le
le le samedi le match espoir par contre
si tout le monde progresse et que que
les joueurs progressent individuellement
et dans le travail de pré ben
automatiquement on aura des on aura des
succès sur sur les sur les les matchs
sport et automatiquement on va
apparaître on va dire dans le top 8 et
on va avoir une é
qui a des qualités mais on veut que nos
joueurs ils aent de l'impact mais on n
pas forcément besoin d'avoir des
systèmes de jeu très élaboré ou de
travailler par rapport à un adversaire
on veut que par rapport à nos profil si
on a le profil d'un joueur qui qui est
scoreur ou un joueur qui est qui doit
être dans l'agressivité on veut qu'il a
cet impact dans le match si on a un
joueur qui doit être sur des timings de
compte c'est un joueur qui doit vraiment
être un shotbocker ou un gros rebondeur
on veut que sur sur les les weekends il
soit capable d'être sur 5 si rebons off
deux trois contes voilà ça c'est des
éléments un petit peu de où on peut
mesurer une évolution une progression
d'un joueur ouais puis des formes de jeu
des formes de jeu évoluer à ce niveau-là
c'est ça va être une perte de temps et
ça se fera à détriment du joueur de
toute façon
Franck eu il nous reste moins de 10
minutes on voulait aborder quand même un
petit peu l'été qui vient de se se
terminer dans lequel tu as été avec le
staff de l'équipe de France je pense que
ça peut intéresser quand même les nos
auditeurs euh même si évidemment le la
thématique du centre de formation l'
tout autant euh nous sommes limités par
le temps donc on avait quand même deux
ou trois questions euh est-ce que tu
peux expliquer comment on amène une
équipe qui est composée de de personnes
qui ont pas fini leur saison au même
moment qui sont pas en forme au même
point et cetera comment on les amène
tous ensemble vers une seule et même
compétition est-ce que là aussi tu
faisais du travail spécifique sur le le
physique justement
comment comment tu fais quelle est ta
recette tu commences à à connaître un
petit peu ma ma vision donc
évidemment j'ai j'ai j'ai tout
individualisé pourquoi j'ai tout
individualisé parce que ma première
ambition c'est c'est que le joueur
accroche soit motivé par le travail
qu'on lui propose à partir du moment où
il se dit si je rentre dans ce
process pour les matchs de la Coupe du
monde je vais être plus en forme voilà
ça c'est essentiel Franck a raison il a
mis le point par exemple sur le fait que
j'ai arrêté très tôt ma saison j'ai pas
beaucoup travaillé pendant l'été il faut
que je me remettre en en marche sur du
travail cardio par exemple un joueur qui
vient de terminer sa saison qui s'est
arrêté jusqu'àun jour c'est c'était par
exemple le cas d'Adrien merm que je
viens de croiser parce qu'il est un
moche en ce moment et Adrien qui est
arrivé fatigué qui est arrivé qui venait
terminer sa saison c'est le travail
cardio à ce moment-là n'a pas de sens
donc il faut plutôt essayer de de de le
de le maintenir à son état de forme pour
pour pour le coup Adrien était était
blessé donc à un moment donné il a pas
eu suffisamment de break et il a il a il
a pas été il a pas pu finir la
compétition avec nous mais chaque
individu vient avec son son histoire
vient avec son parcours et avec son état
de forme donc on ne peut pas gérer ce
cet effectif surtout qu'on est à 16 au
départ et ensuite il y a des couples sur
l'effectif on peut pas gérer cet
effectif si on nindividualise pas les
charges et les objectifs donc ça a été
fait ça a été fait dès le départ
énormément d'échanges avec le club ça je
m'y tiens depuis depuis toujours parce
que j'étis moi-même tu sais comme je
suis préparateur j'étais préparateur
physique dans les clubs mais moi sur les
équipes nationales si tu veux j'ai j'ai
des préparateurs physiqu qui m'ont
appelé en me disant voilà on va faire ça
ça ça l'été et qui ne tiennent pas du
tout compte de ce qui est fait pendant
l'année or toi quand tu es en club tu as
ton joueur pendant 10 mois et ensuite il
part en équipe nationale 2 mois pendant
l'été donc je pense que le minimum et
c'est de prendre un contact avec le
préparateur physique club de savoir
quelles sont les routines qu'il fait
avec son joueur pendant l'année et
ensuite d'appliquer ces routines à
partir du moment où ces routines sont
importantes pour le joueur et derrière
on peut aussi amener un petit peu sa
note et discuter avec le joueur pour
proposer quelques objectifs qu'on peut
avoir par rapport à N nos objectifs
collectifs qui sont de gagner de gagner
ensemble quelque chose une médaille ou
un podium donc communication et
indualisation mon métier c'est de
résumer c'est pas toujours facile hein
c'est facile à dire mais c'est pas
toujours ouais non mais bien sûr c'est
c'est un travail énorme j'avais une
autre question par rapport justement à
au bénéfices que peuvent en tirer les
joueurs alors évidemment l'objectif
c'est la compétition on les a entendu
quand ils sont
revenus il y avait parfois de la de
l'incompréhension quand il voyait
d'autres nations qui venaient pas
forcément sur sur le championnat du
monde en disant voilà ça va nous pourrir
notre saison d'après moi j'ai quand même
une interrogation par rapport à ce qu'on
appelle le pic de forme j'ai
l'impression de je m'y connais très peu
en prépa physique mais de ce que je sais
c'est un pic de forme déjà ça dure pas
longtemps et on peut pas en avoir 15 par
an donc ou donc est-ce que ces
joueursl du coup après la compétition il
faut qu'ils redescendent tout de suite
pour refaire un peu de de de travail de
fond pour revenir en forme au début de
saison et garder le Ry toute la saison
est-ce que forcément ils vont baisser à
un moment pendant la
saison moi si tu veux je ta forme ta
forme à un moment donné elle est liée à
ton niveau c'est-à-dire que si tu tu
t'entraînes très dur ton pourcentage de
mal grass il est il est tout petit ton
niveau d'entraînement il est top tu es
ton cardio est bon tu es changement de
direction au niveau de la prtique
périphérique qui a peu d'impact tu te
sens bien bon tu un très très bon niveau
on va dire très très bon euh euh niveau
niveau de forme ok là-dessus peut se
greffer une fatigue qui est lié à la à
la l'effet cumulé des charges donc tu
commences à à être un petit peu fatigué
tu es moins bien et sur les effet de
fatigue il se pose un petit peu un voile
c'est comme un un voile qui se pose sur
ton niveau de forme et là il va falloir
décharger donc sur ces aspect là tu
décharges et on peut à nouveau voir les
tu reviens en forme tu reviens sur de
fraîcheur et tu peux performer à nouveau
ça c'est ce qui est normal après quand
tu te déconditionnes quand tu arrêtes
que tu breakes que tu ne travailles pas
pendant 6 semaines tu vas à la plage tu
es tranquille là tu te désentraînes et
il faut repartir sur un travail de
conditionnement c'est automatique ça
c'est quelque chose de totalement
différent donc on avait des joueurs à la
Coupe du Monde qui étaient
déconditionnés et on avait des joueurs
qui étaient en forme dont il fallait
gérer le niveau de forme c'est pas la
même chose si tu vois ce que ouais ce
que je veux dire donc forcément après la
Coupe du monde je pense que la plupart
de nos joueurs ils avaient ils avaient
récupéré un bon niveau certains devait
encore un petit peu travailler mais
après il y a un relais qui doit être
pris dans le clubs pour soit maintenir
soit continuer à travailler bon et sur
le plan personnel ce sera la dernière
question puisqu'on arrive à la fin
qu'est-ce que tu as qu'est-ce que tu as
retiré au-delà d'e d'une belle médaille
dans dans ton armoire dans ton salon non
mais écoute c'était encore une aventure
géniale moi j'ai commencé en 2014 alors
j'ai eu la chance de de de de voir
l'équipe de France battre l'Espagne en
Espagne ça c'est c'est juste c'est juste
top puis l'euro l'euro 2015 on a eu
moins de succès après aux Jeux
olympiques mais c'est une c'est encore
une fois une une grande expérience et à
l'euro et là on a retrouvé de la
performance ensemble et sur un un un
scénario avec une dramaturgie incroyable
la victoire contre les États-Unis
ensuite l'énorme déception derrière face
à à l'Argentine et puis les ressources
mentales et puis aller arracher la la
médaille donc donc c'est juste
fantastique déjà d'être avec tous ces
joueurs qui sont qui sont des grands
professionnels et qui ont une éthique de
travail extraordinaire au quotidien
pendant 2 mois et dans l'échange avec
les coachs et de croiser des adversaires
aussi qui sont dont tu ne peux qu'avoir
un énorme respect c'est une chance donc
moi tu vois chaque campagne c'est une
une énorme chance j'espère pouvoir
prendre une une dernière médaille aux
Jeux Olympiques l'été prochain et et
ensuite je tiraerai ma révérence parce
que j'ai j'ai fait le choix maintenant
du coaching donc je j'essaie d'être en
cohérence avec mon projet très bien
messieur une une une dernière remarque
àant ouais je regrette qu'on est pas 1h3
ou 2h parce que je pense que ça aurait
pu être ça aa pu être vraiment vraiment
très très complet comme échange là tout
ça c'est c'est on a fait on a on a fait
on a fait cours par la force des choses
mais parce qu'on a tous des employ du
temps un peu chargé mais en tout cas je
voilà j'insiste que dit Fran là sur la
fin c'est c'est important on a tendance
à mettre les gens dans des cases euh
mais bon c'est il prouve de par le
boulot qui fait liimoge qu'il a fait AC
les prospects l'an dernier qui fait sur
la structuration du centre de formation
et en parallèle son expertise sur
l'équipe de France qu'on peut avoir
qu'on peut voir plusieurs casquettes
tout en tout en restant expert c'est
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant et
disponible qui plus est écoutez moi les
gars je vous remercie déjà pour tout le
travail que vous faites j'adore
envergure parce qu'on on a vraiment vous
choisissez un angle d'attaque qui est
différent et ça nous permet de nous
exprimer de donner voilà un petit peu de
lumière sur des choses pour lesquelles
il y en a pas toujours donc bravo à vous
continuez merci beaucoup merci pour tes
réponses qui étaient fort complète comme
dit romain on aurait pu faire 1h et de
2h on l'invitera peut-être parce que
s'il a des prospects intéressants qui se
développent et des joueurs de qui parler
sur le championesoir ou autre ça peut
être quelque chose à faire à l'occasion
sûr on rest en contact comme disent les
jees grand plaisir de de parler des si
on a un petit peu de succès et qu'on
qu'on VO les garçons progresser avec
grand
plaisir en aura nésitez pas voir jouer
les GAM du C quand même quelques
quelques joueurs quelques joueurs à
garder à l' absolument absolument merci
beaucoup merci à toi franckci rom Manu
merci et nous et vous qui nous écoutez
on se retrouve très bientôt pour pour un
nouvel épisode de cette intersaison qui
va se décliner donc en trois podcast on
garde le mystère pour les deux autres
invités pour le moment merci beaucoup
Ciao co
[Musique]
Co